blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman so yesterday we talked
about the covet healthscape that Florida
has become uh sort of almost like as a
feature of how Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has handled the
covet situation there really uh flouting
not flaunting flouting
um all conventional wisdom and public
health guidelines almost from the very
beginning of the pandemic now we also
have these other Republicans who they've
been vaccinated and if asked they'll say
go and get vaccinated but for the most
part throughout the pandemic they've
played the freedom and liberty game and
mostly sucked up to president Donald
Trump and one such example is Republican
senator from representing the state of
South Carolina Lindsey Graham Lindsey
Graham has now tested positive for
covid-19
and the timing of that positive test
suggests that because of a boat ride he
went on on Senator Joe manchin's boat
um it may even be a sort of mini super
spreader event so let's first look at
what exactly is going on axios reporting
Senator Lindsey Graham tests positive
for covet 19. Senator Lindsay said
yesterday he tested positive despite
being vaccinated Graham emphasized that
the mildness of his symptoms is due to
being vaccinated if he had been
unvaccinated his symptoms would be far
worse he said that's his speculation but
certainly reasonable uh thing to think
it appears Graham may have exposed a
number of other Senators to the virus
after he attended a weekend get-together
hosted by Senator Joe manchin Democrat
from West Virginia on the latter's
houseboat CNN reports
Senator manchin is fully vaccinated and
following CDC guidelines for those
exposed to a coveted positive individual
Senators Mark Kelly Jackie Rosen and
Jackie Rosen were also at the bipartisan
Gathering and are now following CDC
guidelines for persons exposed Senators
Catherine Cortez masto John thune and
Chris Coons all of whom are fully
vaccinated also attended the boat
Gathering thune has already received his
test results and tested negative for
covid Senate Democrats have gone back to
holding virtual meetings in light of the
news of Graham's positive test so I
haven't really thought about Lindsey
Graham for some time but remember that
crazy situation where he refused to be
coveted tested before a debate with I
believe it was Jamie Harrison who was
running against him for the senate in
2020 and so they basically installed a
plastic shield around Lindsey Graham
sometimes you'll see it big concerts the
drummer will have a plastic Shield so
that the drumming doesn't get picked up
by the microphones of other instruments
and people on stage they did the
equivalent but with Lindsay it was a
coveted glass a Plexi Plexiglas or
plastic barrier because he didn't want
to be tested so the point here is
Lindsey Graham has been uh relatively
clear over the last two weeks including
now with his positive test I thanks to
being vaccinated this is probably less
serious than it otherwise would have
been go and get vaccinated it's
important to be vaccinated but for
basically the totality of 2020 he sucked
up to Trump and insisted Trump was doing
a good job on kova despite Trump's job
job on covid being one of the worst in
the world particularly for uh what we
would call one of the wealthier
countries
refused to be tested as part of his
freedom and all of this other stuff and
now he may have been involved in a
potential mini spreader event now again
the the Senators on Joe manchin's boat
Saturday
we're of course of course Joe manchin
himself
uh Mark Kelly Chris Coons John thune I
mentioned Jackie Rosen Senator Cantwell
from Washington and Senator Cortez masto
from Nevada and hopefully all of them
will uh will test negative so there's
been a really interesting you know at
this point it's really depressing
actually that this is the way it is but
signal and the absence of signal both
are being computed the same way by the
anti-masters and the anti-vaxxers when
you so you would think oh okay Lindsay
tested positive despite being vaccinated
and his symptoms are mild so that should
lead people to say I should get
vaccinated so that if I test positive my
symptoms will be mild the problem is
that you'll have some people in his base
who will say oh
he was vaccinated and tested positive
therefore the vaccine doesn't work that
would be one incorrect interpretation of
what happened here and they'll say so I
won't get vaccinated because it didn't
prevent Lindsay from testing positive uh
the other one is well he tested positive
and it's mild so therefore I don't have
to go and get vaccinated ignoring the
reality that there's a good chance we
don't know for sure but there's a good
chance that Lindsay's case is milder and
hopefully it remains milder because he
was vaccinated so to you and me we would
say this is the this is the virtue of
the vaccines working Lindsay is I don't
know he must be around six between 65
and 70. I would guess 67 something like
that he is at a higher chance of a more
serious case he says it's like a cold
right now it's mild and he's vaccinated
so this is the virtue of getting
vaccinated other people will simply find
in that
what they want either you don't need a
vaccine against something that's mild or
you don't need a vaccine that doesn't
work because he tested positive despite
being vaccinated so unfortunately it's
not going to be the Big Boon that you
and I might hope now hopefully he
recovers and then he encourages people
to get vaccinated and at least some of
them listen and understand that this
change we've seen from people like you
know Mitch McConnell claims he's been
for the vaccine all along he got
vaccinated he hasn't been loudly for the
vaccine all along Fox News you know
everybody turning pro-vaccine now the
reason in part we know that the Trump
Administration early didn't really do
that much about covid is they saw it
mostly affecting Democratic blue cities
New York City Boston San Francisco Los
Angeles Etc and so we know because of
the conversations between Jared Kushner
and Trump they just weren't worrying
about it that much because it was mostly
affecting their political opponents
adversaries enemies or whatever whatever
the case may be now it is a very
different situation now the number one
coveted hellscape in the country is
Florida with often 20 or 30 percent of
the entire country's cases are happening
in Florida each day
hospitalizations record in Florida over
ten thousand highest of the entire
pandemic coveted case rates growing
twice as quickly on average in red
counties that voted Trump versus blue
counties that voted Biden so they
realize now they are the ones at risk of
losing voters because of that political
reality that's why they're changing
their perspective hopefully Lindsay
testing positive
Phil Valentine the radio host who was
anti-vaxx and get vaccinated I'm now on
a ventilator hopefully this gets people
vaccinated but unfortunately I think for
many of the anti-vaxxers they will see
this and say oh this is more reason not
to get vaccinated let's look at the
latest I mean it's like to call it a
conspiracy theory is almost like too
much because it suggests there's some
Theory and there really isn't a Newsmax
reporter suggested during a recent White
House Press briefing that the entire
Delta variant might be almost like a
false flag it might not really be a
thing this took place during an
outrageously chaotic press briefing um
this press briefing so let me set this
up for you because the entire scene was
absolute in total bedlam
jensaki did not hold this press briefing
this press briefing was held by the
deputy press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre who did overall a very good
job
um towards the end of the press
conference there was this idea they do
this every once in a while they'll bring
on a reporter via video conference to
ask a question sometimes it's like a
rural reporter once it was someone from
Alaska
um okay so they try to bring on this
reporter remotely and there's just
massive technical issues like we the
viewers at home could hear the reporter
but I guess in the room they couldn't
hear the reporter and then the reporter
was talking at the same time Newsmax
reporter starts talking about the Delta
variant and it gets nuts so I'm still
wondering why Newsmax is even in the
White House Press briefing room I never
I still can't fully understand how that
works we've heard before Oh someone has
lost a seat but they're still in there
at the backgailing questions it's not
totally transparent to me there's some
opacity here okay but let's get to it
and again I'm warning you it's total and
complete chaos in the room like it's
really hard to figure out what's going
on and what's even being said but let's
make an attempt to figure it out
that is the dominance trained in an area
when people just test whether they're
covered calls we don't we don't okay so
the question there and by the way I
don't know if you saw seems to so so far
the mask is off the nose and soon you'll
see the mask actually come all the way
down the question is how can you say the
Delta variant is spreading when when
people get tested it's just are you
positive or are you negative for covid
that's the question it's sort of like is
is the Delta variant even really a thing
people just test whether they're covered
we don't we don't we don't test them we
don't test it we listen to public
I mean that's what they are telling us I
laid out why why I laid out how
contagious it was and I laid out why uh
why we needed to act this this is this
is so frustrating I'm with you guys
later today so
hahaha
uh I I guess what she's saying is
how do we know if something is the Delta
variant if I have symptoms and I go and
get tested and it's sir you're positive
right sir sir I how does is it Delta or
is it not Delta the the explanation is
you sequence the virus you get a cohort
that's representative of the population
and you test them and you sequence the
virus you don't do this with everybody
and sort of like in when you when you do
a political poll you don't interview
every American you get a representative
sample and so the idea would be if 40 of
the sample believes something then you
can extrapolate that roughly 40 of the
country believe something if your sample
is good it's the same thing with the
sequencing the their their test cohorts
and if they see that 80 of the test
cohort is the Delta variant then you can
say well Delta's probably 80 of the
country's a positive test generally
speaking if your sample is good like she
seems to be saying why isn't Korean
Jean-Pierre explaining epidemiology to
her so therefore it must all be some
kind of false flag it continues these
are
these are hold on one second I just said
that Dr Lewinsky said just recently in
her 20-year career she had never seen a
a variant that was so contagious so this
is 20 years of her career I actually
don't think Karine Jean-Pierre is doing
that great of a job here unfortunately
so this is absolutely absolutely a a
major major problem that we are trying
to deal with that's why we heard from
the President yesterday that's why we
keep talking about people need to get
vaccinated so that is that is the that
is the way that we're trying to move in
this Administration making sure that we
are protecting uh people here making
sure that we're dealing with this
pandemic in a way that is effective and
that's how we're going to move forward
I'll take another question so you know
there's I mean what's frustrating about
this is first of all it doesn't really
matter what you call it like whatever
you call it even if you don't even talk
about variants
it has gotten way more contagious that's
call it whatever you want you don't need
to sequence every case you need to
sequence a representative sample if you
want to say wow Delta's now dominant in
Florida you're not sequencing every
individual you're saying let's take a
cohort and it used to be that five
percent of the cohort was Delta and now
80 so that it's becoming dominant the
logic here from the reporter is sort of
like if you've not exactly explained how
gravity works then I should be able to
fly like maybe people can fly because
you're not explaining to me exactly how
gravity works if you've not tested
gravity it maybe it doesn't actually
apply here maybe it's made up and
karine's expression you know it's funny
it's sort of like a combination of
confusion and pure hatred it would have
been better for her to be a little more
prepared because to you and me were like
oh my God it's like this is not an
epidemiology briefing we're testing a
cohort and and that's sort of it to the
conspiracy theorists that comes off like
the Newsmax reporter made a really good
point and there's this incredible
arrogance in there about like if the
Newsmax reporter doesn't understand it
how could anyone and therefore is it
even definitely true and it's like a
combination of belief based on ignorance
and dunning-kruger they don't understand
the science they assume that they do and
therefore they they assume that if the
science was good they would understand
it but they don't and so when they
encounter some kind of uh information
that challenges their preconceptions or
they don't get it like you get a
positive or A negative when you get
tested so how could we know anything
about Delta
um then all of a sudden it reinforces
their beliefs that they shouldn't trust
what's going on you know it's sort of
like hey Karine can you explain the
field of epidemiology in the Press
briefing room oh you can't well then
there must be no Delta and with a lot of
this you know it's it's like start from
the the way I would suggest dealing with
people like this in your private life
and we've talked about this before start
from are you open to the idea that you
might not know everything and I might
not know everything oh okay good if if
you're open to that then we can go to
the next thing
what reason do you have to doubt that
there is a different variant now than at
the beginning like do you have General
doubt about the fact that viruses change
over time do you have specific doubt
about how this right and really try to
break down where the disconnect is but
everything just seems totally confusing
to this reporter she doesn't know how to
wear a mask it shouldn't shock us that
she also doesn't understand you test a
cohort and then you extrapolate from it
it's it's really a sad State of Affairs
my friends not sad is the fact that we
are now under two weeks from our 16th
anniversary 16 years since the start of
the David Pacman show we'll be doing a
one-day membership special on Monday
August 16th I would love for you to sign
up on that day
it's going to be an incredible day it's
going to be an historic day you can sign
up for our newsletter at
davidpackman.com and then Monday morning
on the 16th you'll get an email telling
you how to sign up at a huge discount
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction category stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video so I've been
taking some shots from the audience
about I guess some people in the
audience think I'm too empathetic I I'm
I'm too empathetic when it comes to
people that haven't gotten vaccinated
and then get very sick or sometimes die
yeah I feel bad for those people if if
you want to attack me for being too
empathetic I will take it it doesn't
seem like the worst character flaw to
have uh but I have an example for you
today of someone who is apparently in a
really bad position
and I don't really feel bad and maybe
now people will be mad that I don't feel
bad but the latest report is that Rudy
Giuliani is reportedly close to broke
and now Donald Trump seems to have cut
him off as well there's a very
interesting article in Mother Jones
which says having raised more money than
anyone else in the Republican party so
far this year new filings show Donald
Trump is flush with cash now later we'll
talk about what he's doing with some of
that cash and it's very grifty
absolutely swimming in it but even as
the money flows in the former president
is reportedly stiffing one of his
fiercest allies in loyal political
surrogates Rudy Giuliani as the former
New York mayor becomes increasingly
ensnared in a federal investigation
reportedly costing him millions in legal
fees here's the latest on the apparent
Fallout between the two men Maggie
Haberman tweeted Giuliani allies are
looking at the Trump money even if it is
an 82 million and are aghast that Trump
isn't helping Giuliani with legal fees
Trump doesn't care about anybody when
they are no longer useful to him that's
what's good that's always the case it's
no different with Rudy Maggie goes on to
tweet giuliani's friends say he is close
to broke
and his interview with Melissa Russo
makes clear he knows he's in legal
Jeopardy
going on to say Trump aides have been
clear they see no mechanism for paying
Rudy's legal bills that isn't
problematic for Trump and they think
Giuliani took actions as a lawyer should
have known were problematic
strange phrasing but I understand what
it says even if the client wanted it
that's particularly worrisome for
Giuliani whose legal defense fund has
effectively failed to raise anything in
his fight against the federal probe into
whether he worked as an unregistered
lobbyist for Ukrainian officials
Giuliani who was recently suspended from
practicing law in New York is also
facing a separate lawsuit from Dominion
voting systems over his Relentless
election lies and despite his penchant
for conspiracy theories and
misinformation it appears as Haberman
notes that Giuliani does seem to
understand the gravity of his precarious
legal situation so this is a disaster
for Rudy but it is really a deserved one
quite frankly I mean you know this guy's
an adult he was a competent lawyer he
didn't so much fall for something as he
made some kind of calculation
that he was going to get involved and
defend everything Trump does no matter
what and even go above and beyond not
just while Trump was trying to be
reelected Trump loses and then Rudy
becomes the front person the most
prominent person going around the
country spreading covid and also
spreading bogus hypotheses about how
Trump actually won he turned himself
into a pawn for a psychopathic
narcissistic egomaniac that was Donald
Trump
how else was this ultimately going to
end and a little bit later we're going
to talk about new reports that Donald
Trump has been funneling the grifted 80
million or 72 million or whatever he
raised over the last few months to fight
the election results he's been funneling
it into his own businesses but he's not
going to pay Rudy giuliani's legal fees
so what options does Rudy have close to
broke couple things that come to mind
one I don't know if you remember but
there was there were a few instances
where Rudy mentioned that he has an
insurance policy
he said that he has this insurance
policy which is some kind of evidence of
trump wrongdoing and that if he were to
have a problem with Trump he would have
this evidence of some kind as an
insurance policy did he really have that
we don't know did he have it but maybe
it's not really a value anymore because
it's part of what was seized when his
home and office were raided by federal
authorities a month or two ago we don't
know is Rudy going to have to flip
although then it actually raises
questions you know it's it's really it's
complicated because Rudy was Trump's
lawyer but he was really only like his
TV lawyer until after the election Rudy
actually started filing motions in
courts but then Trump sort of distance
and it's not clear whether that was
really a representation the point is if
Rudy were to think about flipping and I
don't know that he's thinking of that
but if he were is there a question of
attorney-client privilege Village
somewhere in there I don't know I don't
know but it shouldn't shock any of us
that Rudy didn't end up getting 20
million a day from Trump who notoriously
stiffs everybody that works for him so
Rudy is in a bad place
I you know it's it's hard for me not to
feel a little bad the guy's nearly 80 he
may be broke
I feel a little bad I do
but this is really of his own doing it's
not even like Rudy you know an anti-vax
person who's the victim of
disinformation propaganda all around
them they go to work and it's anti-vaxx
propaganda they go on Facebook it's
anti-vaxx propaganda then they get sick
with covid I see them really as as
mostly victims although they are also
perpetrators by continuing to signal
boost the anti-vaxx propaganda
Rudy is not really a victim here Rudy
Rudy's just a lawyer and he made a bad
call he made the wrong decision and now
he's going to have to apparently pay the
price for it hey I'm going to show you
some video that I would get the kids out
of the room this is extremely disturbing
video of Pastor Greg Locke from the
global vision Bible Church in Mount
Juliet Tennessee now the video that I am
going to play for you
um one
it's politically outrageous and crazy
I also don't know if this guy is having
a medical incident during this video I
don't know I'm not a neurologist but is
this a stroke is this guy because this
is out of this world crazy video during
which Greg Locke starts screaming to his
congregation by the way the the services
are taking place in a circus tent which
you you will see if you're watching
which is fitting he starts screaming at
his congregation not to get vaccinated
and that he was right about everything
what he's talking about I don't know but
let's take a look
wow I've been right about all of it whoa
we've been right about all of it
oh yes and you can see there that it is
literally in a circus tent a striped
circus tent
yes
these Wicked fools don't win in the end
they don't win in the end
so all this fear bull crap is that it is
bull crap Say Amen
I know you've never been to a church
where a pastor told you to say amen
after I said bullcrap
[Applause]
like is this this this is is this a
psychotic break
is there any context outside of it a lot
of us see this and we say it doesn't
matter then it's that it's in a church
this is mental illness uh is there any
context outside of a church where you
would see this and not say whoa 72-hour
psych hold
I call it real BS biblical stupidity
biblical stupidity
so I know I wasn't going to say nothing
about it but I think I feel froggy
enough I'm gonna jump right now and just
say this whoa
I am not
apologizing for what I said on this
platform last week
okay
the Delta variant was nonsense then it
is nonsense now you will not wear masks
in this church you will not wear masks
in this church I'm telling you right now
do not get vaccinated do not get
vaccinated I don't care what you think
about me he's getting a standing ovation
for this folks there's a pastor
excuse me in a circus tent
getting a standing ovation for saying no
masks allowed and you will not get
vaccinated don't need your money
don't need your hand clap
you'll need more people on social media
to follow me Socha I ain't following
along with it
Joe Biden's days are numbered
I said they're numbered
I've told you the whole time this
election was fraudulent okay this is a
cult this is a terrifying terrifying
cult even the term Pastor is like what
it's more like cult leader remember
that's that's a tax-exempt church that
is a churches are allowed to be
tax-exempt they're not supposed to do
politics he said the election was stolen
that's politics he should lose his tax
exemption will the IRS investigate
they're not investigating nearly enough
and then the anti-vaxx non-science
nonsense uh this same guy a week ago a
threatened to kick people out if they
wore a mask to his church same guy in
Mount Juliet Tennessee
Tennessee really low vaccination rate as
of yesterday uh 39.2 percent the
national average it's about 50 the
country is vaccinated about 50 Tennessee
is more than 10 points below that at 39
there are States you know Vermont's at
67 Massachusetts 64 Maine 63. Tennessee
is very lowly vaccinated very highly
infected and you have a tax-exempt
church pastor saying do not get
vaccinated Biden didn't really win
how is it that that can be tax exempt
how is it now but now on the other end
who thinks this guy's been vaccinated I
genuinely don't know could he be
vaccinated but he knows that these are
the types of rants that play to his
audience's fantasies and delusions
because a lot of these anti-vaxx members
of Congress that we've found out about
they are vaccinated or at least they
some of them are vaccinated some of them
don't want to say one way or the other I
think we know why
um absolute insanity and you know when
we when we try to understand
how did how do some people in this
country believe the stuff they believe
if you grow up around just that's your
one social thing where you go to a
church in a circus tent and that's what
you see
um and then all your co-workers are
going to that
and your parents growing up tell you
what you see in the media is not true
what you read in history books isn't
true that's how we end up with the
problem we have in this country so we'll
have more on that on our uh Show
Instagram make sure you're following us
on Instagram at davidpackman show uh
coming up after the break I'll be
speaking with Attorney Peter muget that
26 billion dollar lawsuit against the
opioid Distributors and manufacturers
Peter mouge is one of the attorneys who
negotiated it and we will talk to him
next
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
today I'm going to be speaking with
Attorney Peter muget who's a senior
partner at Levin Pap Antonio Rafferty
and also chair of their Securities and
business litigation Department we're
going to be talking about this uh
proposed 26 billion dollar settlement
against some of the pharmaceutical
Industries biggest players uh some of
the details which we talked about
earlier this week Peter it's great to
have you on first of all yeah thanks for
having me Dave appreciate it so talk to
us about first this this is an opioid
related settlement just to remind our
audience as we talked about earlier this
week talk talk to us about the Genesis
of this how did these four organizations
first become the subject of this case
how long has this been going on I'm
going to put those in two different
buckets and we'll talk about the
manufacturers quickly yeah the
manufacturer which is the J J story J J
is both a manufacturer in an importer of
raw opium and they marketed and promoted
the uh opium here in the U.S similar to
a Purdue story and those cases start
started earlier the the beginning of the
the manufacturer cases was 2014-ish the
distributor cases which are the big
three and account for 21 billion of the
26 billion really didn't start getting
filed by the local governments until
late 2016 beginning 2017 and their
responsibilities while overlapping with
the manufacturers are a little different
they have an obligation to review every
order whether it's suspicious because
it's a large size frequency pattern and
they're supposed to Halt shipment and do
due diligence they didn't do it that's
simply their responsibility under the
federal regs and why they're on the hook
for the 21 billion so in general when
people talk about opioids you can look
at essentially any part of the chain of
how these ultimately get to Consumers
and find concerning Behavior so you
could look at doctor and over
prescribing for a period of time
although in some places that has been
mitigated at least to some degree you
can talk about the manufacturer's uh in
terms of the clinical trials sometimes
being accused of misrepresenting how
long the medications are good for in
order to justify FDA approval as being
better than what's already out there you
can talk about Distributors using sales
reps to encourage the purchase and
prescription of more like at every Point
there's there are things that you can
find that go wrong the DEA yeah I mean
there's enough finger pointing to go
around you're absolutely right so my
question Peter is in this case with
regard to the four companies in question
what are what is the alleged wrongdoing
that you were going after in the case
well the Distributors and the
manufacturers but primarily the
Distributors are charged under federal
law with designing a system to identify
orders of unusual size frequency or
pattern we'll call those suspicious
orders and once they flag a suspicious
order they are required to Halt the
order and perform due diligence before
they shipped it and we have been able to
track uh their system that they were
supposed to design going back decades
and suffice it to say to until
2013 14 15 there really was virtually no
system in place so the runaway growth of
the opiate epidemic was driven in large
part that opiate pills were just flying
out the front door with no oversight and
that's what they were supposed to do and
the reason why they're on the hook now
in 14 15 16 it got better but it still
really wasn't fixed and until this
injunctive relief in the settlement
agreement that requires them to create a
Clearinghouse spotting red flags run by
a third party I think we'll finally get
to some real meaningful uh red flag test
on the on the distributor side
the manufacturers are a little different
in that they have the same
responsibilities but a little further up
the food chain and that it's very
difficult for a manufacturer to stop a
shipment from a distributor but they're
also supposed to be performing due
diligence and reviewing inside of this
closed system for suspicious orders but
what we found was is that the
manufacturers went out and educated
doctors on the lack of addictiveness of
the pills and they were safe and the the
information coming from the
manufacturers was often misleading so
overlapping but a little bit different
on the manufacturer themes or side of
the case is it fair to say right now
that the nature of the opioid crisis in
the United States is not quite as severe
as it was when some of these cases
started or is that the wrong perspective
wrong perspective it's actually worse so
what's happened now is we have have this
whole generation of primarily 20 to 40
year olds that are are addicted to Pills
and if we cut the spigot off of pills
The Addictive nature of opium and we've
known this for hundreds of years going
back to we've had multiple I mean Wars
over opium we've had opium problems here
in the United States going back to the
70s with Heroin so what we've seen now
is we've started to ratchet down the
number of pills is that's uh heroin and
Fentanyl has just spiked they're totally
inversely correlated pills go down
heroin and Fentanyl go up and as a
result last year deaths were 30 percent
higher than they were the year before
related to opiate overdoses so we are
not anywhere near out of the uh out of
the problem Zone these cases take years
in many cases they can be very expensive
even from the standpoint of the law
firms that that are carrying these cases
out can you you talk a little bit about
exactly what your role was within this
because these are major undertakings
with a ton of lawyers doing different
things we had it was I'm really proud to
be part of this this whole operation but
our firm formed a Consortium of law
firms meaning a group of law firms a
West Virginia law firm a Dallas firm and
we were the architects of the
distributor case we were the first ones
in the country that filed the
distributor cases almost 70 percent of
the cases in the first year we filed we
were the Architects behind the
distributor case and just as importantly
we were the group of firms that uh
recovered the Arcos database and the
Arcos database tracks every single pill
manufactured in the U.S shipped to a
distributor and then shipped to a
pharmacy we were able to track every one
of those pills and then we designed a
red flag system that we put on top of
every one of those pills in the U.S so
when you saw a hundred billion pills
distributed in the U.S from most 6-14
that was us so we were able to create a
red flag system on top of Arcos and uh
that were that identified the orders
that should have been popped along the
way with due diligence on them
we were able to implement uh that or
include that into our our litigation
showing what the defendants could have
done along the way to prevent this
epidemic so we've been a huge part of
that distributor case our firm and our
our group of firms uh Paul Farrell out
of West Virginia and uh Baron and Bud
along with our shop you know 11
papatonia Rafferty in a case like this
what's the general approach of the
defense Council for the corporations in
and my question is really tailored at
this is it a defense that is substantive
that the average person could understand
or is it a defense that's basically
miring you in technicalities and
obscurity it's both uh the
technicalities and the obscurities are
typically at the and the the motion
practice level and depending on whether
the case is tried in front of a jury or
a judge uh the it's it's primarily
finger-pointing where you started the
show off with uh pointing at doctors and
pointing at patients and blaming
everyone besides looking in the mirror
and that's what's really uh cool about
this this settlement agreement that
we're taking into our clients at least
the Distributors have tried to address
the the mess that they participated in
creating and are looking in the mirror
saying what can we do it's a long-term
problem we need to have a long-term
solution we've got other defendants that
are Distributors like Walgreens and CVS
and Walmart that had even better
visibility than the Distributors because
they were Distributors and pharmacies so
if they were getting shipments from
three pharmacies uh I'm sorry three
different distributors that Walgreens
could see every one of them and and so
there's still finger pointing and not
trying to come to the table and see what
they can do to be part of the solution
so it's it's a uh it's going to take
everybody looking in the mirror figuring
out what they could have done better and
contributing to the solution rather than
this continued the reason why we're here
is because of the DEA is because of the
doctors right or because of the victims
I mean blaming the DEA is ridiculous
it's like blaming the police officer for
getting a speeding ticket I mean it uh
but they're throwing everything but the
kitchen sink on the defense side when we
covered the proposed settlement a few
days ago which is this total of 26
billion 21 plus five for the different
parties involved I got a bunch of emails
you know 10 or 12 12 emails from viewers
saying hey you know to the extent that
this is going to compensate some victims
that's great but in terms of holding
these companies accountable in a way
where they say wow that almost took us
down we can't do that again that it's
not effect active they say because these
companies price in the fact that at some
point this is potentially going to
happen it's just sort of like a
probability curve and they say you know
over the next 20 years we should
consider that there's going to be some
number of billions of dollars that we
may have to pay out we've already got
that calculated in and it's not
ultimately going to affect this or Force
us to change our Behavior what do you
say to that that's those are great
questions and and the your your uh
viewers are entirely correct quite
frankly it's the way our whole system
works and there isn't personal
accountability at the corporate level
that if they get caught uh essentially
the the stockholders the shareholders
pay these fines right no one pays them
so it is short-term the whole system's
designed to drive short-term profits up
so senior level management uh options
package in stock patch packages there
are compensation levels store sore and
then push the problem in the liability
ability down the further down the
timeline for the shareholders to pay
until we start holding people
accountable so they pay these fines and
they're personally kind of on heaven
forbid we actually send somebody to jail
we won't see conduct changes now this is
one of the things that's cool about this
settlement is that the settlement
includes game-changing conduct
requirements that are transformative we
will see
meaningful change within this supply
chain industry so this won't happen
again it's not going to be overnight but
we will see fixes and this money is also
not going to coffers to fix potholes or
go to fill budget deficits almost 90
percent of these settlement proceeds are
being used to treat the opiate epidemic
which is also very very important so the
money's going to fix the problem and
then there's conduct changes that will
prevent this from happening again last
question What's the timing of I mean
it's being referred to as a proposed
settlement right now when might we
actually see the money start to change
hands well one of the things that we
negotiated was an accelerated payment so
the first payments going into escrow uh
this year in August September of this
year it will stay in escrow until we
reach critical mass and critical masses
just sign on from an approval from the
cities and counties across the country
across the country on the timeline I see
that have happening right at the
beginning of next year so first quarter
of next year the cities and counties
will receive two payments one for 2021
and one for 2022 they'll get the second
payment in July and by July of 2023
they'll have their third payment so
within 18 months from January 2022 to
July of 2023 the first three payments
will come in the door which we can
really will be a catalyst to really make
some meaningful change yeah for the
speed at which we're used to these
things moving that seems uh quite uh
quite quite reasonable I guess is uh is
is what I would say we've been speaking
with Peter muget an attorney senior
partner at Levin Pap Antonio Rafferty uh
Peter great to speak uh speaking with
you today and uh glad to see that this
is moving forward thanks David
appreciate you having me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright I
want to talk about not one but two
different apparent Financial scams that
we've learned about over the last 24 to
48 hours I've told you now many times it
is going to take months if not years to
learn the full scope of the grifting and
scamming and and wrongdoing of the
former admin former Administration and
the financial aspect of that are a big
piece of it let's start with part one
Donald Trump's presidential salary we
are still learning more and more about
the different lies around Trump's
finances Donald Trump is reportedly
worth about two billion dollars I know
there are claims that it's like four or
five the best guess is he is worth about
two billion dollars the presidential
salary is about four hundred thousand
dollars okay we now have reason to
believe that Donald Trump despite
promising to donate his presidential
salary that he did not donate the last
six months of salary about two hundred
thousand dollars now remember he pledged
to donate his full salary he said I
don't need the money I'm doing this for
the betterment of the country
yeah uh so I'm going to be donating my
salary to federal agencies there's a new
Washington Post report which finds that
there is no evidence that Donald Trump
actually did that with a salary for the
last six months in office as president
for the first three and a half years of
his presidency he donated the money to
federal agencies The Washington Post
said it looked it surveyed all major
federal agencies and none of them
reported receiving a donation from Trump
uh from the point starting in July of
2020 the last six months of his
presidency the paper said it was unable
to account for that last two hundred
plus thousand dollars of Trump's salary
that was supposedly going to be donated
his last known gift was to the National
Park Service in July according to
government documents so I think the
explanation for what happened here is
very very simple we know that as Donald
Trump's one-term presidency went on
Trump was more and more agitated about
not getting more positive coverage for
the fact that he was donating his salary
I think Trump got sick of the fact that
he wasn't getting the coverage he wanted
Trump is both cheap and greedy so he
said if my salary donation isn't buying
me any positive media coverage I'll just
keep the money that would be very on
brand for Trump I don't think we have to
look very far for a sensible explanation
also by the way making it extra bizarre
that Trump apparently didn't donate the
last six months of salary is that
remember it wasn't I have enough money
so I'm going to stop making money and do
the presidency but donate my salary and
just make nothing for these four years
Trump kept making money while he was
President he reportedly made 1.6 billion
dollars over those four years meaning
that even the salary he donated is like
0.1 percent of what he made and he still
apparently didn't donate the full salary
despite his promise now I think it's
important to mention just to be thorough
The Washington Post clarified
we were unable
to verify Trump's donations and we did
not get a response when we asked for
comment it's theoretically possible that
he donated it somewhere and we don't
know where and we just can't track it
down it's possible but again the point
is he had been doing it to federal
agencies reporting it there were
disclosures there was documentation the
paper trail stops with six months left
to go the paper went to Trump's business
and asked about it uh they went to the
lawyer who the former lawyer who helped
arrange the donations nobody responded
okay now also some may not know Trump
continues to receive a pension of two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year as a former president as well so
there were people who wrote to me and
said David this is a sign that Trump is
broke I actually doubt it that that
would make keeping the money more
logical certainly if Trump was broke it
would make sense to keep that last two
hundred thousand uh Trump's not likely
broke and that's what actually makes the
story even wackier it's it's you know um
uh Trump the the fact that he is so
cheap despite being a two billionaire
is actually even more stunning than
Trump somehow ending up broke but no he
made 1.6 billion during his four years
in the white house I don't think he's
broke but there is an even bigger scam
okay and we're going to talk about this
in a moment Donald Trump has now raised
uh somewhere between 70 and 80 million
dollars from his followers on the
promise that the money was going to be
used to fight the election results to
fund audits to to fund recounts to fund
lawsuits and investigations to try to
overturn the election and put Trump back
in power the latest report is that none
of the money the 70 or 75 or 80 or 82
million that was donated for that reason
none of it actually was used by Trump
for the things he claimed he was racing
raising the money for and of course on
the tail end end of it his supporters
won't actually care he could walk up to
one of them M on Fifth Avenue and shoot
them and they would cheer and assume
that it was secretly antifa or something
like that and what I want to talk about
next is a new report
that uh not only did Donald Trump not
use the 70 or 80 million for what he
said he was going to use it for there
are new disclosures which show that
Donald Trump funneled those donations
into his personal businesses let's talk
about that next so scam Financial scam
Story number one is Trump said he would
be donating his presidential salary
Washington Post can find no evidence
that the last six months of his salary
were actually donated the next piece of
the financial scam is that it is now
believe Donald Trump moved donated money
money donated to fight the unfair
election results to his own businesses
according to new filings check out this
article by Greg graziozzi which says
Donald Trump moved more than 200 uh I
guess it's supposed to be 200 000 200
000 uh dollars donated to his make
America great again pack into his own
private business accounts according to
an analysis of his Federal filings the
money was moved in February a month
after Trump left office money donated to
Pax is meant to be spent solely on
campaign efforts Forbes reports that the
former president also set up a
leadership pack generally used to
support other candidates that's the pack
where he said
I will tell you who the good Republicans
are donate to me and I'll distribute the
money as I see fit Trump took 30 million
dollars from his make America great
again pack and moved it to the new pack
called save America that pack eventually
grew to 90 million dollars and Trump
took an additional 79 000 out of that
pack for his own uses Trump's business
the Trump org regularly interacted with
his campaign packs in one instance the
Trump org charged his campaign packed 38
000 to rent in rent via Trump Tower
commercial LLC of which Trump is 100
owner during 2016 Trump ran his campaign
out of the skyscraper but his 2020
campaign was partially run from DC
despite this the Trump organization
continued to collect rent for Trump
Tower in total the Trump organization
collected 188 000 in rent between
January and June all paid through
Trump's campaign donations Trump
restaurants also collected rent from the
pack even after the former president
left office and during a time when
tourists visiting Trump Tower were few
due to the coronavirus pandemic totaling
fifteen thousand dollars and it just
goes on and on Save America the
leadership pack paid Trump Hotel
Collection 79 000 after Trump was out of
office uh expenses largely for lodging
and meals the Trump organization did not
comment on the self-dealing payments but
the former president did Issue a
statement boasting that his Affiliated
committees have approximately 100
million dollars of cash ready for use
the statement said these fundraising
numbers coupled with tremendous support
in so many other ways showed that
President Trump's supporters want him to
continue to fight
um we
we knew that the PAC save America pack
we we knew the entire donate so that we
can fight the election results we told
you it was a grift back in December
January February if you looked at the
fine print when they were sending out
the fundraising emails it would say we
can use up to what up to 50 cents of
every dollar donated to pay off campaign
debts for example
um this is really it's almost like a
political version of the producers and I
still go back to the idea that Trump's
entire 2016 primary run was really just
a way to make money and get publicity
and become more more well-known and then
monetize it after losing the Republican
primary or certainly after losing the
election but Trump overestimated
apparently the intelligence of his own
electorate of the Republican Party
electorate and when you do that weird
things can happen and the weird thing
that happened was that the Republican
electorate was actually ignorant enough
and radical enough to vote Trump to be
their nominee
um and his followers still to this day
believe he was draining the swamp or
whatever it was so again it's just like
with Trump's salary this amount of money
should really be meaningless to Trump
like 79 Grand into the Trump Tower
restaurants and uh 20 grand or a hundred
grand or 188 in rent these are amounts
of money that should be meaningless to a
guy like Trump who even by the
conservative estimates has two billion
dollars
um but this is It's greedy cheap and
narcissistic and what will his followers
say probably nothing that's the reality
if you go to his followers
um they they will say listen this this
is a guy with why would he go to some
crappy restaurant when he has his own
restaurants where he can hold campaign
events why would he rent some office
when he owns so much real estate it
makes sense that he would do this they
will defend him uh to the last day it
was a grift from day one and the
financial documents seem to support it
will there be consequences for
self-dealing probably not probably not
uh but uh it is certainly the type of
thing where if it were Democrats doing
this it would be 24 7 on Fox News it's
not even a story on right wing media
though we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here is a really
good question about the right and the
pandemic beautifully asked take a listen
to this
yeah hey David this is uh Troy calling
from uh Georgia yeah I just had a
question for you that I don't think I've
ever seen anybody ask
you know people that are against vaccine
and mask mandates yeah
um I've always wanted somebody to ask
the opposing side well what is it that
you want our government to do right to
fight this pandemic nothing because I
haven't
heard any other suggestions of what we
could do other than mask up and try to
get everybody vaccinated yep do they
want to just let
this thing run rampant yeah here's the
this is a great question right so you're
against the government saying what
should happen in schools let schools and
parents figure it out
you're against government saying you got
to wear masks you're against government
saying you got to get vaccinated to work
here to work there to go here there to
travel in this particular way you're
against businesses having capacity
limits they want to leave it to the
business to decide leave it to the
people to say oh I I want to go to this
business or I don't I'll everybody will
just kind of make their own decisions
this is the point they they don't want
anything to be done many of them never
believed it was serious enough to have
anything done involving the government
many of them believe that anything
government does is overreach and yet now
they're okay with government passing a
ban on mass mandates and so it's
completely hypocritical but you have to
understand their framing is it should be
Freedom leave it to people and
businesses to figure out
except once a business says well you've
got to wear a mask to come in or you've
got to be vaccinated to come in then
they want to pass laws that say no no
you can't do that ban mask mandates ban
vaccine requirements to do business so
it's the wrong approach this this is
sort of like
when we say
aren't Republicans going to be punished
for obstructing everything Democrats
want to do no no no the obstruction is a
feature if your world view is I don't
want government doing anything or I want
government doing as little as possible
you see obstruction by government
officials
as a feature rather than a bug they are
doing the thing you want them to do they
are preventing government from doing
stuff and so of course it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
extraordinarily dangerous and we see how
it's worked out for the United States
and particularly when you look at the
red States now or the red counties now
case rates growing at twice the rate in
red counties as in blue counties it has
failed completely it's a perfect
question if not masks if not vaccines if
not how do they think government should
be involved in fighting this pandemic
many of them believe government should
not be involved and that's a horrifying
thing and most of them would concede
even small government conservatives
would tend to concede government should
keep us safe from threats
the threat doesn't have to be a military
threat from another country
it doesn't have to be a cyber threat
from another country or Bad actors it
can be a medical threat a public health
threat and that's exactly what it is so
that it's uh you have to really get into
their mindset to understand they want
the government doing nothing they don't
think the government should be involved
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about what's in the
infrastructure Bill what's actually in
the bill that is going to be debated in
the Senate we will talk about how a
million Texans have registered to vote
online since a Court ruling said you can
register to vote online we will also
talk about new McDonald's policy every
employee must wear a mask every customer
must wear a mask there are McDonald's
addicts who also hate masks who are
going crazy what will they do will they
go to Burger King will they go to
Wendy's will they maybe make a salad we
will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show get instant
access by signing up right now I mean
it's truly instant the speed of light at
joinpakman.com
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman